Bye, Michael.
Hello, how's everyone doing?
Great, fantastic. How are you?
Doing all right, living the dream. Anybody get rained on with Ash?
No.
You had a volcano in the Philippines suddenly pop.
Yeah, it's in the province, yeah, yeah, way, way far.
Yeah, you flew in there.
Well, it said an hour away from Manila. And I was like, to me, now, mind you, where we live here in the Northeast, in the greater Boston area, an hour and a half is less than 20 miles.
Mhm.
Yeah, not here.
Yeah.
I think it's 9 hours drive.
Yes, and you can.
Oh, I heard one hour. Okay, my bad.
You can take it by plane. Yeah, you can take it by plane also. Yeah, that far.
Okay, my bad. Yeah, so I was like, I was like, I was reading this, I saw the photographs. I said, well, this is fascinating. Check this out.
Mm.
Yeah, it was bad for the people living there, but overall in Metro Manila, we're good.
Yeah.
Oh, I...
I heard there was no real warning. It was like you got some warning to evacuate, but otherwise it was like they like the news that was getting here to the United States was there are people like getting off the plane for vacations.
and being like, it went boom. You know, it was one of those deals. Like the few active volcanoes that we still have here in the United States, like there's only a couple of them.
Mhm.
Not once has anyone ever blown its stack without us knowing like ahead of time. And this was the situation 40, 50 years ago with Mount St. Helen in Washington, where it, from what I understand, it blew up the exact same way as St. Helens did, where like most of that volcano like fell in on itself. This is, we like that type of news here in the United States.
Yes.
No.
So, it's when Saint Helens went, they had time to evacuate, and there were people like, "Ohh, it won't be that bad."
Mhm.
It's like, yeah, those people aren't here anymore. You know, it's, I mean...
It.
He.
It's so bad that I'm laughing, but yeah, come on guys. It's the same here. To be honest, I didn't even know that it's happening.
Yeah.
It's okay. He goes, you know what's going to happen? Yeah, it's like we have rules in the, we have terms for that in the United States. It's called Darwinism. It's, yeah, see you later. It's okay. You want to stay here?
Have fun!
Aarav.
Yeah.
You know, if it's...
You know, the Constitution of the United States is also written that, yeah, you have the right to be stupid too.
Hi.
Yeah.
So...
I gotcha. Well, thanks for that, Michael. I am glad that you're updated with the national news. Glad to hear it.
Yeah, well, yeah, when I, the photographs were fascinating though. The photographs were quite impressive. They were real, that was really, that was really neat when I saw that. I was like, okay, that's cool.
True.
Mhm.
You should see the videos also.
So.
I bet, like, you know, people around the back of scooters and all that, like with their video cameras going, come on, let's take a good picture and the rider's like, no, I want to get the hell out of here.
Yeah.
Kip.
Yeah, there were some type of videos like that. Anyway, enough for the volcanoes. I'm, you're seeing a new face currently. So that's Mark. So I'm going to introduce you. Remember I told you that Rodge is taking up a more senior role now within IT by Design. But again, we're not going to leave you guys hanging without support locally.
Wheres.
Yeah.
unfortunately had to deal with me for the past weeks or months even. But I'm bringing in one of our team leads here in IT by Design. He's been with the business for 12 years, but I'm not going to steal his thunder. I'm going to let him introduce himself. Go ahead, Marky.
Hi Michael. So yeah, you can call me Marky. And yeah, like Andrea said, I've been working with MSP industry for about 12 years now. So my previous company is from Australia. The name is First Focus. So what I'm doing there is not just being the team lead, but...
Hi.
Is.
Also, I'm managing their incident management, which is responsible for P1 and P0 tickets. And aside from that, I'm also doing the dispatch coordinator role there before. So I have three functions during my stay there, and I'm handling there after ours team.
It consists of 18 staff members from Manila, Australia, India, Ireland, and South Africa. So basically, I'm manageable with the process that we have for MSP. So I'm looking forward to working with you.
You had me on the locations until you mentioned Ireland. I was like, that's not in the Pacific.
Yeah.
So, yeah, seems like, um, yeah, they're trying to...
All right, fair enough.
It was like...
South Africa I got. I get that. I've seen that before. I've seen Asia Pacific work with, you know, so I get the Australia, New Zealand, right, the different islands, all of that, Macron Asia I get, and then all of a sudden you're like in Ireland and I'm like...
I'm not sure why. Yeah, I'm not sure why they expanded there, but maybe in the future they are going to get some clients there. I'm not sure.
Somebody did it wrong.
Understood. All right. Appreciate it. Thank you. It was just a bit off.
Yeah.
Got it.
Gotcha. All right. So yeah, so moving forward, Michael, Mark will be with us and he already met Andy and Kath. So they were able to touch base and just wanted to introduce to you moving forward. You'll be the one assisting the engineers with anything that they need, that be admin, troubleshooting, but of course,
Mhm.
So be with me, reporting under me and you know, all the things that you needed to work with under the POC. Okay.
Appreciate it. Thank you.
You're welcome. So I'm going to share my screen now and then we can go ahead and proceed with our April. So this is going to be your bi-weekly service review for April. But before we go ahead and do that, I know that you are.
Busy is not even a term for you anymore. I don't know what is more busier than busy. But do you want this to move on a monthly basis after a quarterly reviews next week?
I apologize. One of the things you're going to learn, Marky, if that's how you want it to be pronounced, it is that I'm doing multiple things at once. So a lot of these meetings ending up being canceled. So our vice president of managed services is hitting me up right now. So I'm going to ask to skip this.
Ohh.
Right, the bi-weekly service review is perfectly fine. I know I'm the one, I know I asked for it. So, but it's right now it's I'm not going to be able to give it the respect it's due because I am doing multiple things at once and I'm being hit up why certain people are doing certain things. So just for the record, this may not be normal for most of your customers. This is normal for me.
Yeah.
Okay.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Okay.
It is, it is like, you know, is this what you want? I'm like, yeah, this is what I wanted. I go, unfortunately, I've got a vice president going, what the hell's going on with XYZ right now? So hang on a second.
PH.
Okay.
I.
So just give me one second.
Sure, take your time.
Because what's happening is he's like, I want an answer right now. I want an answer right now. I want an answer right now. And I'm like, nope, you're not going to get one right now because I need to talk to people and I'm talking to a vendor. By the way, for the record, he's the one that hooked us up with you as a vendor. So I'm like.
Yeah.
So I'm basically telling them, I'm like, I'll get back to you. I will. Just give me a minute.
So...
Okay.
All right, the priority for me for this week is to have Katrina starting her weekend work as soon as possible. So it is, which to me in my mind is not this coming weekend, but the weekend following.
Mhm.
Okay, so.
Right, that should that should work with the one-week notification and the time off and all that, correct?
Yes.
All right. So as of right now, she should be starting training on our escalation procedures, as well as what's necessary for on call. Now, she's going to be the first person with this style training. However, just FYI, some of the things that she's going to be get trained on.
Mhm.
We'll also be trained with Andy because I'm going to start moving responsibilities for on-call paging, conference calls, priority one coordinations, basically service desk work, where those responsibilities are going to be with Andy and Katrina during the week.
Because, um, it it's just it takes those responsibilities off.
Come on, Jay. I apologize. I'm trying to take those responsibilities off, right off my people, 'cause they're gonna be working on it.
Let me look.
He's going on a speech in a rant and I apologize and I'm like, Jay, I don't have the information. I get what you're trying to say.
Let me do my job and I'll get back to you.
Right, he's a VP. It's like.
Hold on, man. It's just, you know, it's the reason why I'm here. So I apologize. I want to have the service desk, going back to the service desk point. I'm going to be slowly gearing the service desk up with more responsibilities. Mark, this is exactly what the goal we've been working on. Andrea has been working with me. It's just, it's been moving at a slower pace than anyone expected. And I'm okay with that.
Mhm.
All good.
Probably.
Mhm.
It is, it is, I, in my mind, I, it's not that I had low expectations, it's that I have expectations of what a success looks like. So I'm slowing it down so we can meet those, we can meet that metrics of this is what it looks like being successful, which means I'm moving slowly to make sure that the training and everything's in place.
Okay.
Mmh.
Right? So it is, and we've been, you know, turning on certain features. I want you to do this, I want you to do that, I want you to do this, I want you to do that. Another reason for that, as you clearly saw, is that this organization is very tribal. There are, our policies and procedures are not properly defined. And the reason for that is this company was scaled based on technical ability.
not operational control. It's one of the reasons why I'm here. So in other words, a lot of the documentation that we're trying to teach these people on doesn't exist. Why does all this matter? This matters because we're about to train Katrina on how to do all of this on weekends, and that runbook and that information of how to do this may not actually fully exist.
Mm.
So we're going to very carefully train her on how to do that, record it, get all that information, make sure that it's accurate on our end, and then train Andy or anyone else who's going to be coming along the pipeline for the service desk. See how we're doing that?
Yep.
So...
That's my ask. My ask is starting not the 10th, not the weekend of the 10th, but starting the weekend of the 15th. And we worked on, Andrea, did we, did we...
agree on a schedule because I wanted to overlap with the week and I wanted to overlap on a Monday because Mondays are our big days with people in the office.
Yes.
Yeah, I think I sent you an email just to confirm that. I think we talked about Tuesday, Wednesday.
I'm so sorry. I have no doubt you sent me an email of that. I'm confident on.
Yeah.
It's all right. So we are talking about Tuesday, Wednesday isn't off. But over this weekend, it's going to be split off basically. But we can talk about that. So that she has an overlap of Monday and Friday all throughout the week.
Sure.
Yep.
That's what it was. Yep. And on top of that, this show also line up when Andy returns back from vacation. And yeah, so this is a good place to do it. Okay.
Yes.
Gotcha. So I would want to know also because they were following up. They actually thought it's going to be May 2nd. And I was like, nope, there was no confirmation. It's going to be the same. I haven't received any confirmation from Michael. So it's going to be the same. And there were.
So did, you're exactly correct. So did we, and then we ended up running into issues on our end. And so it was like, okay, all right, we'll push it, we'll push it, we'll push it.
Mhm.
Okay.
Gotcha. Also with the training, do you know who's going to train Kath? When will it happen?
So it should be happening as we speak. The main person taking point on that is going to be Matt Blanchett.
Yu.
Mhm.
So, he is the he is the team lead of the networking team, and the reason why I've asked it is because it will be.
95% of the priority one issues that are going to occur over the weekend will be network related.
Mhm.
But this one just.
And it is simply just a numbers game of our customers.
Most of our customers are not going to have.
those levels of issues when it comes to server and infrastructure and things along those lines. And if it does, the escalation is just going to be the same anyways because the on-call person is going to be the on-call person regardless if it's networking or infrastructure, right? Then they will make the decision on who are the appropriate individuals to bring in.
Um...
Mhm.
Gotcha. Understood. Okay, so do you need anything or any help with that? I would assume not because it's all your internal processes. And then for the schedule, once, you know, she's all trained up, I'm thinking of letting her have like a rest day on the 12th and the 13th.
So, yep.
Yeah.
so that she can fully go on the weekend schedule starting the 14th. So that is Thursday.
Well, Andy.
When is Andy Randy's coming back the 14th or he's coming back this 7th?
Um, he's coming back at 11, which is next Monday. Yes.
Eleven.
The 11th. Okay, yeah, perfectly fine then. I'm okay with that.
Okay, so I'll sort, yeah, I'll sort it out. I'll have Marky send that email to HR so that we'll make sure that she's off. One more thing that we were, what we wanted to reschedule with you was this, this cadence, right? That was the sort of this call, we're doing it bi-weekly.
after our QBR, which I wanted to confirm also with you if we're going to proceed to that next week. But okay.
Yes, please. That's a confirmation. I do want to see that.
All right, cool. So we're going to proceed with the RQBR on the 11th, and then right after that, we can go with the monthly service call. Good. All right. Perfect.
Okay.
Yeah, I think that'll be good.
All right, I think we wanted to also confirm that on the 25th of May, we, it's a ITBD holiday, it's the 25th Memorial Day. So I just wanted to know if you're full of operational, do you need the guys to still come in?
No, we're going to need to come in as of right now. Tell you what, let me email you about that later today because I'm going to want the, I need service desk support. I do believe it's Memorial Day as well here in the United States. So it is one of those, like I don't even pay attention to holidays anymore just because I'm used to running teams that
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yes.
Like I got people working every day, every holiday. It's the nature of the beast. So let me get a confirmation on that. But as far as the service desk is concerned, yeah, assume that I'm going to have them work. If that either way, I will get you confirmation on that.
Mhm.
Ohh.
Cool.
Sure, I'll make sure that we sent you the to-dos right after this call so that you have good minutes of what we're going to do moving forward. Last ask would probably be, I think this is when Mark has been pulling out the reports for their utilization, the ticket handling, the ticket closure.
All right.
So just see, I think one of the things that the guys are not doing just yet is tracking their time accurately. I know that it's been all over the place, but I think that's one of the things that is an opportunity for the service desk, because if they learn it at a later time, it's going to be difficult for them to actually understand or remember to do it on a daily basis.
Mhm.
So that's what we're going to improve on because we know that they triage dispatch a ticket. But do you actually count your non-billable admin tasks as a category when you do your timesheet?
Very good question. And that is we will be because the biggest offender of non of admin and non-technical that he's not tracking his own tickets is this guy. So I, they brought that up. They noted where they were. I was just like, look, I'm just getting it done because I don't consider myself one of the frontline people.
Okay.
Mhm.
that actually works with the customers. Well, I work with customers a lot, especially when it comes to on an escalation point, whether they need to or not, right? Like, I'm giving solutions for technical issues. So it also suddenly got back on, well, we need to be tracking that time. And I'm like.
True.
Ohh.
Oh, you know, just the sort of like, yeah, I haven't been doing that. So your question is perfectly timed. Yeah, it's a good, it's a.
Just.
Yeah.
I'm not really used to when I started with MSP, now I used to timing it, but well, it's seated for the business so that they can actually track what's been happening. So I would make sure that, you know, moving forward along with Marquee, Marquee would be coaching the guys and how to do that. And also because...
So, I...
Yep.
to be honest with you, it's not just aqueduct. People here are very utilized. Engineers from different partners and clients are very well utilized. They're working on a lot of things, but then...
Kip.
It's an industry challenge. It really is. And to your point, right, getting your hours correct for we know what your people are doing, but at the same time, your people are working with our customers. We know what they're doing as well when our customers ask. I mean, it really is that simple. And it's...
Yes, yeah, so we.
Mhm.
Yes.
It's good business all around. And I mean, I'm the biggest defender of it. I am absolutely the biggest defender of it. It's it is it is I'm working with customers all the time and I track none of it because it's I just I don't think myself along those lines. And it's like.
True.
Yeah.
Yeah, Aarti.
Thank you.
You know, I've had a vice president go, yeah, but aren't these four resolutions yours? I go, yeah, and they're like.
The.
Track the time and I'm like.
Point.
I gotcha. So we're going to do that moving forward.
Yeah, I mean, I don't punch, I don't punch a clock. I don't, I don't do any of that, yeah.
Oh, same.
But I got coached, so moving forward, we're going to do that. We'll make sure that they understand the importance of that now, so that in the future, they won't be having difficulties in tracking it. So they'll be masters soon enough. So those are the opportunities that we are seeing currently.
Mm.
But again, we'll be providing you the entire ticket utilization, all those numbers since you started with us, which is December until April. Those are the data that we have. So it's going to be a QBR next week. We'll let you know what would be the biggest hurdle of opportunities and what we wanted to do.
Yeah.
on the moving quarterly business review. OK.
OK.
Excellent. Thank you very much.
You're very much welcome. Anything else aside from the things and points I've mentioned?
No, just that we, I'll probably find some time at some point to take a look at the slideshow. I do want to look at it. I do need that information. I've just been heavily distracted right now with the, and there he goes again. On trying to figure out what this is, I'm literally going to get off this call and go contact a few people to go, what's going on?
Mmh.
Mhm.
Kour.
But I did want to have this call because it is, we're making a change to the, we're making change to a schedule as well as I'm giving you a heads up that yeah, more information is coming our way. Plus you want to do a mature training on time capturing, which not to repeat words, but the timing of that is very good for us.
Okay.
because we're doing the same internally.
Cool. We'll make sure that both Gath and Andy are on top of that then. All right, I wouldn't hold you for too long. I know you're busy. So I'll see you next week and we'll be moving forward with the QBR. Okay?
So...
OK.
Appreciate it.
I appreciate that. Oh, and Mark, one thing, please. Communicate with me with email for the moment. We are not a Team shop.
Yep.
Okay.
All right.
unfortunately. So while many of us are versed in Teams, it is simply not configured on our machines for it to notify us. Andrea, we've missed communications so many times because it went through Teams because we're not looking. It is because this organization has is a seller of Cisco products.
Okay.
They use the Cisco products, we use WebEx and things along those lines. Our workstations are just simply designed to react to WebEx.
regardless of whether or not I agree with it, is meaningless. It is, it is, this is just the way it is. So while I am a preferred Teams user, I simply don't have it configured because we don't use it as a standardized tool in-house yet. So yeah, just email us the preferred communication, please.
Yeah.
Okay, no worries.
Okay. I learned, Michael. I sent you a Team message. I sent you an email. Double.
All right, appreciate it.
Yeah, I appreciate that. And I was in a Teams meeting with a customer when you popped up and I was like, oh, this I can reply to, you know, and it's, yeah. All right, thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I gotcha. Thank you. Have a good day. Bye.
Okay, thanks Michael. Nice meeting you. Bye.
Nice meeting you. See ya. Bye.
Time.